is the M2 Max ship worth it over the M2
Pro on the brand new 2023 MacBook Pros
well that's exactly the question we're
going to answer in this video by doing a
bunch of different testing including CPU
based benchmarks and real world tasks as
well as graphic space tasks because this
is mainly a graphics upgrade because the
M2 Max has double the GPU cores 38 on
this 16 inch compared to 19 on this one
and believe it or not graphics is not
the only advantage of the M2 Max because
it also has a secret benefit for the CPU
as well and I'll explain that in just a
minute but first I want to talk about
the ssds now other than the GPU core
difference this M2 Max does come with
the one terabyte SSD compared to 512 on
the base model and this 512 model does
have half the nand SSD chips compared to
the previous M1 Pro and you can see that
reflected in amorphous disk bench almost
two times faster for the read speed and
almost two times faster for the right
speed as well so that's going to help
with transfers and for the SSD memory
swap performance as well so I would
definitely recommend if you're getting
one of these new M2 Pro or Max machines
get at least one terabyte to solve this
issue now something unique about the M2
Max is that you could actually
including the M2 Pro 16 inch and this
actually has a major advantage as you
can see with geekbench 5 open right here
the M2 Max's clock speed is 3.68
gigahertz compared to only
3.48 on the M2 Pro that's 5.7 higher in
terms of the clock speed which should
lead to higher performance and geekbench
single core and as I'm running this test
I also want to mention that this one has
32 gigs of RAM compared to 16 on the M2
Pro and holy moly look at that score
2006 66 on the M2 Max compared to 1959
on the M2 Pro they're supposed to have
the same exact chip at least how Apple
marketed it but yes that's the only way
you can get that high on a Mac right now
as with the M2 Max 16 inch and high
power mode and even for multi-core we
have a higher score 50 200 compared to
14 700 so it's slightly faster in every
single way for the 16 inch m2x model now
in terms of web browsing we can actually
test speedometer 2.1 which is a web
browser Benchmark and this correlates to
the single core score which impacts your
kind of snappiness and web browsing
performance and there's our score 425
compared to 406 that's about four
percent higher so it is ever so slightly
faster because of that high power mode
being available with a higher clock
speed and now let's forget about those
benchmarks let's do something that's
actually real world like this website
builder using figma basically design now
this was provided to us by 500 designs
which is one of the best Design Studios
out there and this basically shows the
workflow of somebody building web sites
and web pages now the goal of this test
is to see how smooth you can kind of
zoom in and how fast it kind of loads up
you can see it's kind of pixelated right
there and let's see in weight how long
it takes it there you go that's full
quality right there now let's test it on
this one
let's see along oh yep that was quite a
bit faster that definitely opened it
faster than the M2 Pro so a little bit
Improvement there and then for the
second part of this test I'm actually
going to grab a timer and then export
these same 12 layers or 12 web pages and
see which one finishes sooner so as you
can see it's downloading the images
right here at the bottom and as soon as
it's finished downloading I'm going to
start the timer and there you go it is
finished and surprisingly there is not
much of a difference one minute and 35
seconds to export on the M2 Max with
double the ram 32 gigs which could be
important because we did get a pop-up
saying this webpage is using significant
memory so it's using a lot of that Ram
but the M2 Pro took one minute and 38
seconds just three seconds longer so for
web design even with double the ram it
didn't even make that big of a
difference so keep that in mind I want
to do a teaser of the graphics
performance in geekbench 5's metal while
this is running I do want to give a huge
shout out to our sponsor Josue that's
doing some awesome offers right now with
pool sway you can centrally control all
of your it systems like desktops servers
and network devices all at your
fingertips how cool is that whether you
need to run a script remotely connect to
a system reset a password or simply shut
your system off Josue has you covered
and the best part it works from
literally every device check out their
special offers right now through their
link below and secure the Limited Time
pricing by starting a free trial today
and there you go we have our scores for
Metal Graphics 84 871 on the M2 Max 52
309 on the MCU Pro that is pretty bad
scaling instead of getting double the
performance as you'd expect with a
benchmark we're actually only getting
about 62 percent higher and that's
because geekbench does not scale that
well with these Apple silicon chips
because it has little gaps in between
the tasks asks so it sits idly compared
to other chips that have no problem with
this so let's do something else that can
scale a little bit better and that is of
course the gfx bench metal test because
it is very optimized and this time I'm
going to run both the 4K and 1440p
versions of the Aztec Ruins High tier
off-screen tests so let's go ahead and
hit start and there's our scores wow
that is much better in terms of scaling
180.3 FPS on the M2 Max for 4K compared
to 92 that's 95 scaling instead of the
perfect 100 that is as close as I've
ever seen between this this is actually
super impressive so much better than the
M1 Pro to M1 Max which was around 80
scaling so much better I think Apple
fixed something here and we have for the
1440p 397.8 compared to 210 that's about
89 so not as good but still better than
it was previously so I'm very happy to
see this and you know what let's just
throw in 3dmarks Wildlife extreme
unlimited test because I do want to
monitor the frequencies with acetop
right here now we're going to be looking
at this GPU usage right here we both
have 1398 megahertz for the GPU usage so
the same clock speed on both but one
really interesting thing that I noticed
was that we had Peak wattage of
49.9 Watts on the 38 core M2 Max
compared to
27.1 Watt on the M2 Pro so that is not
exactly twice the wattage but close to
it there you go we have our scores we
have 150.7 FPS on the M2 Max which is
really really good compared to 77.7 on
the M2 Pro that's 94 higher so still
really really good at GPU scaling and it
actually used 84 more power to give us
94 more performance so it's actually
really good and efficient based on these
results right here actually looks like
it's going to be worth it for people
doing gaming to buy the 38 core M2 Max
because this performance is insane and I
am going to be doing a gaming review so
subscribe right now so you don't miss
out on that video and now before I dig
into some real world testing for the
graphics like blender 3D rendering video
editing and Final Cut Pro and other
video related tasks I do want to test
out cinebench R23 to see how that single
core frequency of 3.68 transfers over to
actual single core tasks and multi-core
differences as well and the first thing
I want to point out is that we have 3.7
gigahertz right here as you can see on
the M2 Max but it estimates the
multi-core to run at 3.3 now over here
on the M2 Pro we have it say 3.5 for
single core but the same 3.3 multi-core
so first up let's just run a single core
task all right this is weird guys look
at this the M2 Pro 16 inch is running at
3.5 megahertz exactly but look at this
the M2 Max the more expensive one is
only running at
3.26 I wonder if that's going to impact
the speed because this is supposed to
run at 3.68 we're not even seeing that
we're not even seeing 3.5 now
interestingly we're almost done with the
test and now the M2 Max is running at
3.4 and wow would you look at that there
is almost no difference 1671 on the M2
Max compared to 1642 that is
1.7 faster which is basically no
difference at all so even though we had
a big difference in geekbench 5 5.5
faster only 1.7 here so for some reason
it's not utilizing that full frequency
and now let's do the multi-core stress
test but first we've got to do the
giveaway with Max yes we are right here
thank you guys for subscribing for
watching our Channel and if you didn't
care about the giveaway please still
subscribe if you guys enjoy our videos
and if they're helpful to you and the
way we're doing this is we have all of
the videos we have made since the
announcement of the giveaway that's
actually 13 videos we're gonna choose
one at random let's hit generate and
it's video number nine so I have the
playlist right here which is actually
our first ultimate comparison oh yep
that's the M1 Pro versus M2 Pro 14 inch
so I put in the URL we filtered out
duplicate comments and there's almost 9
000 here 8400 and now let's choose the
second video for the second winner video
number one which one is that that is the
M2 Pro Mac Mini the Mac mini versus Mac
Studio so the second one right here is
going to be for the Mac Mini winner all
right here we go we have the start
button let's hit that let's do it we're
loading up who's gonna win in the 14
inch MacBook Pro
Mod this one has over 5 000 unique
comments let's hit start all right
I agree I tried very hard in that video
so we will reach out to you guys and if
you enjoy the content once again enable
notifications subscribe even if you
didn't want to enter to win we
appreciate it all right let's get back
to City bench running the multi-core
test this is going to be a 10 minute
throttling test now this time around I'm
gonna be using MX power Gadget which
shows us all the info we need to know
all right guys this is really weird
right now the M2 Pro is actually getting
slightly hotter than the M2 Max and it's
using more power 36 watts compared to
35.5 it's almost like the CPU on the M2
Pro is somehow faster in terms of
multi-core alright so we're almost seven
minutes into this test and surprisingly
these things are handling it super well
we have 102 degrees Celsius on the chip
on the M2 pro 101 on the M2 Max bow both
around 2000 RPMs on the fans and I can't
really hear anything they're so silent
even at 100 workload for seven minutes
so I got my thermal camera right here
let's actually take a look
at the hottest temps we have the M2 Pro
41 degrees Celsius
M2 Max between 40 and 41. yeah 40 right
there so
surprisingly the M2 Pro is actually
running a little bit hotter oh my
goodness guys check that out the M2 Pro
for 2500 the base 16 inch just beat out
the M2 Max of course is barely any
difference about 130 points but you know
what because this is Max tech let's take
it to another level I'm gonna do both
cinebench and 3D Marks Wildlife extreme
stress test at the same time to
basically put the CPU and GPU under a
100 load which is going to stress out
this thing more because it has 38 cores
it is going to get very hot and most
likely it's gonna thermal throttle there
you go they're both running let's
monitor the frequencies 3.26 for
performance no difference 1.4 for GPU
now I am seeing 1.37 1.3 yes this
thing's already throttling the GPU down
slightly oh it's 108 degrees Celsius oh
my goodness that is hot now the
performance core is clocking down look
at that under three while the M2 Pro
still fine above three same GPU this
thing is throttling the M2 Pro is using
more wattage 61 package power compared
to 60 59 on the M2 Max it's using less
power even though it has so many more
GPU cores that is incredible this thing
is limiting itself like crazy opening up
TG Pro you can see fully maxed out on
the M2 Max and slightly off on the M2
Pro so it's not going as fast definitely
louder fans on the M2 Max with the high
power mode all right we're nine minutes
in and let's check the temps wow look at
that 48 degrees Celsius on the M2 Pro no
49 super hot and looking like 45 degrees
Celsius right there is the hottest spot
and that's because the fans are blowing
hotter getting rid of that heat faster
which is why why we see the hottest spot
on the display right there holy moly the
M2 Pro got a score that's 14 higher than
the M2 Max and that is how much those
extra GPU cores are causing thermal
throttling and lowering the CPU
performance wow that is insane of course
this is an extreme test that's
unrealistic it's forcing both the CPU
and GPU to be at 100 workload but it's
still a crazy thermal throttling
difference and now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to leave the wildlife
extreme Benchmark running so I could see
the thermal throttling results of that
as well but my last thing I want to say
is that if the 16 inch is throttling
this much imagine what's going to happen
with the 14 inch 38 core M2 Max all
right now this GPU test is going the fan
speeds are down but the weird thing is
the M2 Max I saw the GPU clock down to
as low as 1.25 while running which is so
weird it doesn't make sense well the M2
Pro is at 1.4 gigahertz non-stop this is
really weird alright we finally have our
scores and this is very interesting
19911 for the best Loop score on the M2
Max compared to 12 779 that's 55
higher which is a lot lower than we saw
in the original test where we had 95
scaling that was great it's down to 55
now when we included both the CPU and
the GPU however if you look at the best
and worst scores in terms of this stress
test with all these Loops it actually
didn't change that much which means
while we were running cinebench it was
prioritizing the GPU the entire time and
choosing to clock down the performance
cores in the CPU instead so it focuses
on GPU performance which is a good sign
for graphics related tasks and now with
that theoretical Benchmark stuff out of
the way let's move on to some real world
Graphics tests which is very important
for you guys we're starting off with
blender 3D rendering on both of these so
let's go ahead let's render this image
this is BMW using Cycles on the GPU and
wow would you look at that that is close
to two times scaling 22 seconds for the
M2 Max with 38 cores compared to 41
seconds on the M2 Pro that's actually
really impressive now here I have party
tug I'm going to be rendering this thing
out but what I am noticing is that the
M2 Max is loading everything up a lot
quicker than the M2 Pro definitely an
advantage in terms of loading all these
shaders or whatever's here once again
let's go ahead and render and this time
I'm going to open up MX power Gadget and
look at that wadded scaling we have 14.5
Watts on the M2 Pro and 28.6 Watts on
the M2 Max so almost using double the
power which is what we should be seeing
with 38 cores you have to really power
those to get some good performance so
I'm glad it's scaling well in that way
and would you look at that a minute and
four seconds only for the M2 Max
compared to two minutes and two seconds
on the M2 Pro once again close to twice
as fast this is the scaling that I
wanted to see I'm so happy that
blender's working so well let's do one
more blender test this is going to focus
on memory there you go it's finished 14
seconds on the M2 Max 22 seconds on the
M2 Pro they both have the same kind of
peak memory usage
18.8 gigs I believe so both very fast
the M2 Max in this case is around 50
faster so overall really good
Improvement for blender 3D rendering
let's move on to video editing and Final
Cut Pro all right here we are with a
five minute hevc test now this is the
most popular format that people use both
hvc and h.264 which is why we're going
to export it and see which one gets done
faster and there you go they're done the
M2 Max finished in a minute and 14
seconds compared to 2 minutes and 20 on
the M2 Pro so over a minute faster on
the M2 Max and it's actually not because
of the 38 GPU cores because they were
barely being used this is actually being
limited by the video encoders and the M2
Max has two of them instead of one on
the M2 Pro which is why it's so much
faster so that's a huge difference For
You video editors out there and now the
same thing apply eyes to prores since
the M2 Max has double the encoders and
decoders of progress so I have prores
raw open a five minute clip let's export
it and see the difference and wow this
is actually not as big of a difference
the M2 Max finish in 44 seconds compared
to 58 on the M2 Pro so it's actually not
that far behind in terms of prores
footage but still a big advantage on the
M2 Max and now for the final craziest
test this is Canon R5 raw this is going
to be an export right off the bat we're
hitting 108 degrees Celsius already on
the M2 Max we're starting to get some
throttling right here in the performance
cores yes it is going down while the M2
Pro is still fine and there you go it is
finished the M2 Max took 6 minutes and
43 seconds for this export and the M2
Pro finished in eight minutes in 41
seconds so about a minute and 58 seconds
longer than the m to Max and that
honestly isn't nearly as big of a
difference as we saw on the other tests
of course because of the thermal
throttling and now with all that testing
out of the way let me give you my
thoughts on the M2 Max versus the M2 Pro
because this model right here with the
one terabyte SSD and 32 gigs of RAM is a
thousand dollars more expensive and that
is a lot of money so is it worth
spending that much money well here is my
answer if you're just doing CPU based
tasks it's definitely not worth it
because there really isn't that big of a
difference even with the faster single
core frequency it doesn't really show
that much of an improvement in the real
world so cpu-based tasks just stick to
the M2 Pro now as far as GPU if you're
doing gaming yes upgrade it is worth the
FPS difference because the scaling is
much better this year we saw 95 scaling
in Wildlife extreme and gfx bench that
was amazing and if you're a video editor
the then definitely upgrade to the M2
Max but keep in mind that you might not
even have to go up to the 38 core
because those dual encoders is what's
giving you the huge Advantage there so
that's what you want to look for for
video editing if you're doing blender 3D
rendering absolutely upgrade to the 38
core such a huge difference almost twice
as fast in those tests that we ran so to
be completely honest I am more impressed
with this year's M2 Max than I am with
the previous M1 Max because of the
scaling issues going away and having
much better scaling this year so there
you have it if you're making money or if
you're depending on your work and time
is money for you then it's worth
upgrading but honestly this M2 Pro is
more than fast enough for the majority
of people out there I'd even say that
the M2 MacBook Air is fast enough for
most people so if you've really really
really care about performance and time
then it might be worth worth upgrading
to the M2 Max so with that said if
you're not ready to upgrade to one of
these new ones you could just get a
better deal on a refurbished M1 Pro or
Max machine using the YouTube tagging
feature below and definitely subscribe
because I'm worried about the 14 inch M2
Max we're gonna do a thermal throttling
video for that as well so subscribe
right now and check out one of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next one
[Music]
thank you